My name is Yana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the clinical psychologist collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself.
我叫雅娜，是一名心理健康从业人员规培生。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书。我发现书中关于各种不同经历以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的故事非常有趣。通往这个职业的道路竟然有这么多，而且没有一条是完美的必经之路，这让我感到十分惊奇。这在某种程度上让我充满了信心，让我知道我并非在做错误的选择，同时也减轻了我的心理压力。
So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. Have you ever done something at work or maybe even being asked to do something at work that just didn't sit right with you.
因此，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些心神不定，我绝对推荐你读读这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦你翻开这本书，就绝对放不下了。你是否曾在工作中做过某件事，或者甚至被要求做过某件事，但这件事却让你觉得非常不对劲？
Something that made you feel like you'd betrayed your own values even if you were just doing what you've been told or working within the system. That feeling might be more than just discomfort. It could be moral injury and it's something that more and more of us are experiencing in education, in healthcare, in policing and in other public service roles too. Stay tuned to get the lowdown on what moral injury is and what you can do about it. Hope you find it really useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne, a qualified clinical psychologist. Thank you so much for being here.
这件事让你觉得自己背叛了自己的价值观，哪怕你只是在照章办事或者在体制内工作。这种感觉可能不仅仅是不舒服那么简单。它可能是道德损伤，而且越来越多的教育、医疗、警务以及其他公共服务岗位的从业人员正在经历这种状况。请继续收听，了解什么是道德损伤以及你可以采取哪些应对措施。希望你觉得这期节目真的很有用。欢迎来到《有志成为心理学家》播客。我是玛丽安博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。非常感谢大家的收听。
I first became aware of the term moral injury in 2020. At this time, I was being trained, able to support the Covid situation that was unfolding. At that point, we didn't really know what it was going to be like, but we were planning for the worst whilst hoping for the best. As part of that, I was trained to kind of do debrief situations for people who had been through very challenging work situations. That is where the term moral injury first came onto my radar. It's definitely been around before that, it's definitely been around since that. I just
我第一次知道“道德损伤”这个词是在2020年。当时，我正在接受培训，准备应对当时正在爆发的疫情。在那时，我们并不知道情况会发展成什么样，但我们做好了最坏的打算，同时也抱最好的希望。作为培训的一部分，我接受了相关指导，以便为那些经历过极具挑战性的工作状况的人们进行压力疏导（Debriefing）。也就是在那时，“道德损伤”这个词第一次进入了我的视线。在此之前它肯定就存在，在此之后也一直存在。我只是
didn't know the term and so I thought, you know, four years later why not tell you about it because I think it's something we should all be more aware of, both for the impact for ourselves in our roles but for those around us as well. They might be our friends, they might be our colleagues, other people might be experiencing this, our family members maybe even in their work situations and I think it's it's big, it's important, it should get airtime. So let's take a little bit of a look to some examples in a variety of different roles for how moral injury might show up. During the pandemic
以前不知道这个词。所以我想，四年后的今天，为什么不跟大家好好聊聊这个概念呢？因为我认为我们所有人都应该对此有更多认识，无论是为了解它对我们在岗位上的影响，还是为了关注我们身边的其他人。他们可能是我们的朋友、同事、家人，甚至可能在他们自己的工作环境中也在经历这种状况。我认为这是一个重大且重要的问题，应该受到广泛关注。因此，让我们来看看在各种不同的岗位中，道德损伤可能会以怎样的形式出现。在疫情期间
frontline healthcare workers were asked to decide who would get access to ventilators. Imagine the psychological toll of being forced to deny someone life-saving treatment simply because there weren't enough resources available. Mental health professionals working in overstretched services are sometimes, or in my experience often, asked to add people to waiting lists knowing full well they might not be seen for two or even three years. When someone is clearly in distress and in need of immediate support that can feel unbearable. In policing, officers might be instructed to respond in ways that go against their own
一线医护人员被要求决定谁能获得呼吸机的使用权。试想一下，仅仅因为资源不足而被迫剥夺某人拯救生命的治疗机会，会带来怎样的心理负担？在资源超负荷的服务机构中工作的心理健康专业人员，有时——以我的经验来看是经常——被要求将患者加入等待名单，尽管他们心里很清楚，这些患者可能需要两年甚至三年才能得到面诊。当某人明显处于痛苦之中且急需即时支持时，这种状况会让人感到难以承受。在警务工作中，警员可能会被指示采取违背他们自身
judgement or values. For example, they might firmly believe that someone ought to be arrested or prosecuted for something that's happened, but they might be told that there wouldn't be enough chance of prosecution or that there aren't enough resources to follow that through. That can sit very unhappily indeed. In education or safeguarding, it can be very difficult when you're having to address specific needs for certain individuals in your class, when actually you know that that is a detriment
判断或价值观的方式行事。例如，他们可能坚信某人应该因发生的某起事件而被逮捕或起诉，但他们可能会被告知，起诉成功的几率不高，或者没有足够的资源来推进此案。这种结果确实会让人感到非常憋屈。在教育或特殊教育需要支持（Safeguarding）领域，当你必须照顾班上某些特定学生的具体需求时，如果你明知这会对
to others in the class and in the school. That can be a very bitter pill to swallow. So none of these situations are easy, but actually when we're asked to consistently do things that go against our values they stack up and can lead to emotional friction and over time that can look like guilt, shame, blame, withdrawal, anxiety, depression, even trauma symptoms, kind of hyper vigilance, feeling like you're not worthy of anything. Perhaps you get kind of intrusive thoughts or memories or
班上和学校里的其他学生造成损害，那将会是非常艰难的抉择。这真是一个难以咽下的苦果。所以，这些情况没有一种是容易面对的；但实际上，当我们被要求不断做那些违背我们价值观的事情时，这些压力就会累积起来，导致情感上的摩擦。随着时间推移，这可能会表现为内疚、羞耻、自责、退缩、焦虑、抑郁，甚至创伤症状（如过度警觉），让你觉得自己一文不值。也许你会产生一些侵入性的想法或记忆，或者
maybe sometimes even flashbacks to some of the people that you feel have been not having the experience they deserved along the way and you might notice that they just feel like kind of little jagged bits that you keep tripping over that you keep coming back to. That's an indication that that's not sitting right and that this might be a moral injury or even you know a bigger traumatic presentation. So how does moral injury show up emotionally? People experiencing moral injury might be feeling like they've let others down or betrayed themselves. They might be feeling powerless
有时甚至会闪回浮现出那些让你觉得在整个过程中没有得到应有对待的人的面孔。你会发现，这些经历就像是一个个小小的带刺绊脚石，让你不断被绊倒，思绪一次次回到过去。这表明情况不对劲，这可能是一种道德损伤，甚至可能是一种更严重的创伤表现。那么，道德损伤在情绪上是如何表现的呢？经历道德损伤的人可能会觉得自己让别人失望了，或者背叛了自己。他们可能会感到无力
and like they're in a broken system. They might be feeling anxious or ashamed. They might also be feeling isolated from their colleagues, especially if no one else is talking about it. That can be incredibly invalidating as it makes us think it's just me, I'm the problem, everyone else seems to be okay with this. Moral injury also can make it really hard to trust ourselves. You might start to wonder am I even a good person? How can I continue doing this job with integrity whilst also feeling like I am living authentically to myself and my own values. Like I said, it might well affect your sleep, it might well affect your wellbeing, it might
并且觉得自己身处一个破碎的体制中。他们可能会感到焦虑或羞愧。他们还可能感到自己与同事隔绝，尤其是当没有其他人谈论这个话题时。这种感觉会极大地消解我们的心理支撑，让我们觉得“只有我这样，问题出在我身上，其他人好像都觉得这很正常”。道德损伤还会让我们极难信任自己。你可能会开始怀疑：我到底是不是一个好人？我怎么能一边觉得自己在对自我和个人价值观保持真实，一边又带着这种感觉继续这份工作？正如我所说，它很可能会影响你的睡眠，影响你的福祉，甚至可能
feel like you've got a lot of problems weighing down on you. It may even interfere with your functioning, your ability to get through the day, to do the things that you would usually do like shower, prepare meals, eat, sleep, pick up your children, do your own homework or your own work or your the things you'd usually be interested in like you know going for a run or to the gym like it's really impacting on your functioning and when this becomes really problematic this might also impact on your risk to yourself and others. So practical steps. What can we do about moral injury? The first step is actually recognising that it's happening, giving it the name.
让你觉得背负了沉重的负担。它甚至会干扰你的正常运作能力，影响你度过每一天、完成日常事务的能力——比如洗澡、做饭、吃饭、睡觉、接送孩子、做作业或工作，或者去做你平时感兴趣的事（例如跑步或去健身房）。它确实对你的正常生活功能产生了严重影响，而当这种状况变得非常棘手时，它甚至可能会增加你对自我或他人构成风险的可能性。那么，有哪些实际步骤呢？我们能对道德损伤做些什么？第一步实际上是认识到它正在发生，给它安上一个名字。
I am experiencing moral injury. That was definitely something that I felt was problematic for me when I was working in the NHS. The long waiting lists felt very complicated. I was often doing the majority of the psychology assessments so for me the people on waiting lists were real people with names and that was really hard, really hard to manage that waiting list knowing that those people were out there and they were waiting and really wanting this service and I'd had that connection with
我正在经历道德损伤。这绝对是我在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）工作时感到非常棘手的问题。漫长的等待名单让人感觉非常复杂。我经常负责大部分的心理评估工作，所以对我来说，等待名单上的每一个人都是有名字的真实个体。要管理这个等待名单真的很难，因为我知道那些人就在外面苦苦等待，极其渴望得到这项服务，而我和他们之间已经建立过这种联结。
them. I began to feel like I was letting them down. So the second step is seeking support, speaking out about it. Moral injury thrives in silence. Finding spaces where you can process and reflect is key. And actually moral injury can be indicated in burnout. If you would find learning more about burnout, please do check out the very special series, which was created for the aspiring psychologist by Dr. Claire Plumley, which is called Burnout Bites. You will find a playlist for that on YouTube if you want to catch all the
我开始觉得自己辜负了他们。因此，第二步是寻求支持，大声说出来。道德损伤在沉默中滋生。寻找可以进行心理加工和反思的空间是关键。事实上，道德损伤也可能是职业倦怠（Burnout）的一个征兆。如果你想了解更多关于职业倦怠的知识，请务必查看由克莱尔·普拉姆利博士（Dr. Claire Plumley）为“有志成为心理学家”专程录制的特别系列节目，名为《倦怠点滴》（Burnout Bites）。如果你想一次性收看所有
episodes together. So options to find that support. So I think supervision can be so powerful and so important but this can be indicated, contraindicated if your supervisor or your person who's managing you is actually part of this moral injury problem. So finding supervision with someone where you can freely explore that without judgment, without shame, can be really really important. It might even be immediately that you do some peer supervision so that you can get a sounding board, so you can get some validation, you can kind of try and work out whether this is really what you think it might be. Finding some sort of
单集节目，你可以在YouTube上找到相应的播放列表。那么，寻找这种支持的途径有哪些呢？我认为督导（Supervision）可以是非常强大且重要的，但如果你的督导或管理者实际上就是造成道德损伤问题的一部分，那么这种常规督导可能会适得其反。因此，寻找一位能让你在其中自由探讨、免受评判和羞耻感的督导，可能会非常非常重要。你甚至可以立即开展一些同伴督导（Peer supervision），这样你就能有一个倾诉的对象，获得一些心理确认，并弄清楚这是否真的是你所认为的那种情况。寻找某种
supervision or conversation that is values based, that really helps you think it might be. Finding some sort of supervision or conversation that is values based that really helps you think about your values, your integrity and what operating within those values would look like for you can be really important too. There are also peer communities there might well be Facebook groups for kind of people working in your organization or similar organizations and there might be people that you know already who do a similar job and you can talk to. Certainly the Aspiring Psychologist membership is a really lovely place to be able to have safe and supportive conversations and to be able to kind of test the limits of what is normal. You need somewhere where you can feel safe to be vulnerable and seen and that your values are seen as an asset. Part of this process in naming it
基于价值观的督导或对话，真的能帮你理清思绪。寻找某种基于价值观的督导或对话，能真正帮助你思考你的价值观、个人诚信，以及在这些价值观下运作对你而言意味着什么，这也是非常重要的。此外还有同伴社群，比如组织内或类似机构从业人员的Facebook群组，你也可以和那些做着类似工作、你已经认识的人交流。当然，“有志成为心理学家”会员专区是一个非常温馨的地方，能让你在这里进行安全、支持性的对话，并测试正常状态的底线。你需要一个能让你感到安全、能够展露脆弱并被看见的地方，在那里，你的价值观会被视作一种资产。在这个过程中，通过为之命名、
and externalizing it and talking it through might help you realize that actually where you're working is the problem and kind of in terms of the culture and the change that I spoke about with Kelly Lovesy in our recent episode about starting a job and hating it. So you may decide that actually what you are choosing to do is to leave, to find yourself a new job where you are being appreciated and supported, where you are being able to work towards your values within your integrity and free of moral injury. Of course, union or HR representation might also be helpful for you to feel supported and to help have someone advocate for you.
将其外化并进行讨论，可能会帮你意识到，真正有问题的是你工作的地方，这就像我和凯莉·洛维茜（Kelly Lovesy）在我们最近一期关于“开始一份新工作却又讨厌它”的节目中所讨论的文化和变革问题。因此，你可能会决定，你实际的选择是离开，去找一份新工作——在那里你能得到赏识和支持，能够秉持诚信并在不脱离价值观的情况下工作，且免受道德损伤的困扰。当然，工会或人力资源部门（HR）的代表也可能会对你有所帮助，让你感到自己得到了支持，并有人为你发声。
Being a mental health professional myself, I'm of course going to suggest mental health treatment. I think that this is definitely strongly indicated and strongly in the trauma family. So therefore you might want to access a PTSD type treatment such as eye movement desensitization and reprocessing which is all about the eye movements or the tapping to help you to process that so that it lays flat and so that it's assimilated, blended into
作为一名心理健康专业人员，我当然会建议进行心理健康治疗。我认为这绝对是非常适用且强烈指向创伤类别的状况。因此，你可能会希望接受某种PTSD类型的治疗，例如眼动脱敏再加工疗法（EMDR），这主要是通过眼动或轻拍来帮助你处理这些经历，使其平息、被消化并融入到
your life. That could be trickier to do if you are still in the same environment and you're still being asked to make the same decisions and live in the same way that is layering more moral injuries on top of each other. But yes, it's not impossible we can help you to feel better even if you are still in that situation. I guess kind of accessing some curious reflection and some compassion around grief, you know what you've lost out on, what you've been through, what you've endured as part of those experiences can be powerful too. Compassion focused therapy can be life-changing and I think and liberal sprinklings of that can do so much in whatever
你的生活中。如果你依然身处相同的环境中，依然被要求做出相同的决定、以相同的方式生活（这会一层又一层地叠加更多的道德损伤），那么要做到这一点可能会比较棘手。但是的，这并非不可能，即使你仍然身处那种困境中，我们也能帮助你感觉好一些。我想，围绕悲伤展开一些充满好奇心的反思和同情——比如你失去了什么、你经历了什么、作为这些经历的一部分你忍受了什么——也会非常有力。以同情为焦点的疗法（CFT）能够改变人生，而且我认为，在无论你接受的
therapy you are receiving. So we've had a quick look at what moral injury is, how it might show up for us and what we can do about it. I think it's lovely that you have integrity and that you want to do the work you do but you deserve to thrive as well. You shouldn't be having to compromise your values. Your values are what makes you you. I think as humans we have these fantastically tricky brains which do help warn us about things that aren't sitting right. But over time if we continue to ignore that we can struggle with our mental health. We do experience burnout. It can be detrimental to our life, to our career and to those around us that have to kind of watch us shrink to be able to anathetize ourselves enough to carry on going into work and doing these
是哪种疗法中，适时点缀这种同情疗法都会发挥巨大作用。所以，我们刚才简要探讨了什么是道德损伤、它会如何在我们身上表现出来，以及我们能对此做些什么。我觉得难能可贵的是你很有气节、想要做好你的工作，但你也理应蓬勃发展、拥有良好的状态。你本不该被迫妥协自己的价值观。你的价值观造就了独一无二的你。我认为，作为人类，我们拥有极其复杂的大脑，它确实能帮我们对那些感觉不对劲的事情发出警告。但随着时间推移，如果我们继续忽视这种警告，我们的心理健康就会陷入挣扎。我们确实会经历职业倦怠。这会对我们的生活、我们的职业生涯以及周围的人造成损害，因为他们不得不看着我们日渐消沉，好让自己变得麻木，从而能够继续日复一日地去上班、做
things every day. You don't deserve to suffer, you deserve to thrive and I believe you can find a work situation in future that feels more validating, that feels more like a bit of you and that maybe you can even adapt the situation you are in at the moment to help that be true, to help that be the case. If you are an aspiring psych and you would find some more support helpful please do check out the aspiring psychologist membership and also the brand new ready to rise program, which is more intensive and involves one to one with me and runs for a whole year. What is not to like? There'll be details in the show notes. If you found this helpful, please do
这些事情。你不应该遭受痛苦，你理应蓬勃发展，我相信你能在未来找到一种感觉更有认同感、更契合你的工作环境，甚至你还可以调整目前所处的环境来让这一切变为现实、让它成为可能。如果你是一位有志成为心理学家的朋友，并且觉得需要更多的支持，请务必查看“有志成为心理学家”会员计划，以及全新的“蓄势待发”项目（Ready to Rise program）。该项目更具密集性，包含与我的一对一辅导，为期整整一年。有什么理由不加入呢？节目shownotes中会有详细信息。如果你觉得本期节目有帮助，请务必
like, please do subscribe, please do drop a comment, share this with your networks and if you're listening on Apple Podcasts please do rate and review the show and on Spotify you can drop questions and answers and you can rate the show too. Please do come along to the free Facebook group The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr Marianne Trent which is the unique home of Marianne's motivation and mindset sessions which happen on Friday mornings. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide.
点赞、订阅、留言，并将本期节目分享给你的社交网络。如果你是在Apple Podcasts上收听，请务必给节目打分并写下评价；在Spotify上你也可以留言问答并为主播评分。欢迎加入免费的Facebook群组——由玛丽安·特伦特博士创立的“有志成为心理学家社群”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community），这里是玛丽安周五早晨动力与思维特训独一无二的家园。如果你正准备成为一名心理学家，那就让本期播客成为你的指南吧。
With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast Being qualified is the aspiring psychologist's past guess Without a marriage entrance My name is Diakolola Amujo. I am a recent psychology graduate from Ireland. I am also an aspiring clinical psychologist. Dr. Marion's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, has been so helpful to me on this journey to becoming a clinical psychologist. As I plan to continue postgraduate studies in the UK. I found it extremely useful that this book provided in-depth information
有这档播客一路相伴，你将走上获得专业资质的道路。这就是《有志成为心理学家》播客。获得资质是有志心理学家的必经之路。我是迪亚科洛拉·阿穆约（Diakolola Amujo）。我是一名近期毕业于爱尔兰的心理学专业学生。我同时也是一名有志成为临床心理学家的求学者。玛丽安博士的书《临床心理学家合集》在我成为临床心理学家的旅程中给予了极大的帮助。由于我计划在英国继续攻读研究生，
on the UK decline site application process. I enjoyed reading about the experiences of both qualified and trainee clinical psychologists. The various narratives were my favorite part of the book as everyone's story was different and it provided amazing insights into the clinical psychology journey. I would definitely recommend this book to anyone interested in psychology and aspires to become a clinical psychologist. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现这本书提供了关于英国临床心理学博士（ClinPsyD）申请流程的深入信息，这极其有用。我很喜欢阅读合格的临床心理学家以及规培生们的亲身经历。各种各样的个人自述是我最喜欢这本书的部分，因为每个人的故事都各不相同，它为通往临床心理学家的旅程提供了惊人的深刻见解。我绝对会向任何对心理学感兴趣并渴望成为临床心理学家的人推荐这本书。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。